Hi! I'm Ana.
Welcome to 'What to Say!'
Do you know what to say when you respond to news?
Listen out for useful language for responding to news.
Then, we'll practise saying the new phrases
– after this.
Yes, yes, yes!
Ah, I did it!
Good news, then?
Yes! I won the award!
Oh wow!
Congratulations!
Thank you!
It's so exciting.
I can't believe it!
I know!
That's wonderful!
Well done, Noelia. I'm really pleased for you.
WHAT?
You
cannot
be
serious!
Oh dear.
What's happened?
They sent me the wrong email.
I didn't win.
Someone else won.
That's awful!
Yes, it is.
I'm so sorry, Noelia.
What a shame.
Can I do anything to help?
Please
pass me that magazine.
Thanks.
Hello again!
Oh,
poor Noelia!
That's really disappointing.
So,
did you notice the useful phrases used for responding to news?
Listen to me and then repeat.
Oh wow! Congratulations!
I can't believe it.
That's wonderful!
Well done. I'm really pleased for you.
Oh dear. What's happened?
Oh no, that's awful.
I'm so sorry.
What a shame.
Can I do anything to help?
Try and use some of these phrases the next time you respond to news in English.
Bye for now!